mein Gott Schatzi bitte
hallo zusammen
wir lassen uns heute das Rezept geben
von einer künstlichen Intelligenz haben
sie es mir gezeigt ich habe mir so
gedacht wow
ich brauche dich nicht mehr okay
aber das testen wir heute ob das Rezept
wirklich gelingt Alter
aber es gibt ja auch schon so Rezepte
online also schon immer oder Kochbücher
bitte Frau und so sind Rezepte
[Musik]
also nicht im backcontext aber so
generell ne ne
künstliche Intelligenz du kannst eine
Frage stellen und der beantwortet die
also zu allen Themen ihr könnt sogar da
für die Schule das benutzen oder vier
Stunden
halte ein Vortrag über Kolonien im 16
Jahrhundert im 16 Jahrhundert begann die
europäische Expansion und andere Teile
der Welt
und ich habe auch gehört das ist jetzt
kein Kompetenz aus dem Internet aus
Wikipedia sondern nicht
cool kannst du sie mal fragen ob sie mit
Slogan finden kann erstelle einen Slogan
für meine Firma Kikis kitchen in
Klammern Thema backen
für noch mehr küchenfreude auf einigen
Produkten
Vorschlag
süße Träume werden wahr bald
etwas
humorvoller wir machen Kuchen keine
kaloriengruppe
also das darf man merkt also
man kann immer die Fragen noch mal ein
bisschen spezifischer stellen und das
haben wir gleich auch machen mit dem
Rezept ne ja und jetzt habe ich mir
gedacht okay worauf haben wir Lust also
ich hätte Bock auf irgendwas
wir wollen erstmal gucken wenn wir das
Rezept eintippen klappt überhaupt
natürlich sicher
Cheesecake mäßiges ich glaube du
wolltest dir was schokoladiges wir
können das ja kombinieren erstelle mir
ein Rezept von einem saftigen
Schokoladenkuchen mit Cheesecake Kern no
back in der Springform Größe 20 cm let's
go also die Relation zwischen Keks und
Butter ist gut das würde passend also
Kekse 100g Butter ist okay Füllung 55
Grad 250 g Schokolade Zartbitter ja
Puderzucker und zwei Teelöffel Vanille
Extrakt wieso steht da jetzt den Boden
aber nee die hat uns falsch verstanden
wir wollten ein Schokoladenkuchen wo der
Kern ein Cheesecake ist 6 einhalb
Stunden später okay also sie versteht
nicht Kern und Füllung das können wir
abhauen also zu kompliziert sollte es
glaube ich nicht sein Weg von dem
Gedanken jetzt Cheesecake weil das halt
echt nur so viel Zutaten
zusammengenommen
erstelle ein Rezept für einen
Schokoladenkuchen mit flüssigen
schokoladenkern also ich stelle mir da
so einen Kuchen vor wo das richtig
lavamäßig dann in der Mitte rauskommt
genau so eine 20 cm Form das passt
Zutaten dunkle Schokolade mindestens 70
Prozent Verkaufsanteil wenn ich was
nicht habe dann hole ich so schnell und
du schreibst ich habe das nicht ah ja
warte mal direkt doch hier eine Tafel
habe ich noch 100 Grad
[Musik]
dunkle Schokolade 70%
kein Problem
kein Problem aber das finde ich jetzt
wirklich schön weil es ist eine
angepasste Version und nicht wieder ein
neues Rezept das finde ich
achso das ist kleiner als geworden
okay das ist jetzt das gleiche halbiert
aber eine 18 cm Springform
so ich lege jetzt los und lese dann auch
währenddessen die Zubereitung den Ofen
auf 180 Grad vorheizen das habe ich
gemacht eine Springform einfetten ich
habe jetzt keine 18 cm Springform
sondern den Tortenring das kann ich auch
eben vorbereiten beim Tortenring am
besten immer irgendwie Backpapier unten
drunter und einschlagen deine Springform
müsst ihr das natürlich nicht der hat ja
schon Boden ah ich hole ihn mit
Backpapier Moment genauso dann einfach
den Tortenring in die Mitte legen Moment
weiß vielleicht hätte die ich das mache
wenn ich jetzt gar nicht wüsste wie das
will ich gleich im Anschluss mal
ausprobieren so und jetzt einfach das
Backpapier immer wieder einschlagen bis
sie am Ende angekommen seid
[Musik]
genau also eigentlich stelle ich mir das
dann auch gleich direkt auf mein
Backblech aber ich bin jetzt so Hype
dass ich jetzt einfach mal anfangen
möchte ich habe jetzt hier schon mal ein
Wasserbad vorbereitet denn hier steht
die Schokolade und die Butter in einem
Wasserbad schmelzen und gut verrühren
Wasserbad ist einfach ein Topf mit
Wasser wo dann ein Topf noch mal oben
drüber kommt ich habe jetzt hier so ein
Schmelztopf und da einfach dann beides
rein tun und schmelzen lassen eigentlich
starten so auch viele meiner sehr
schokoladigen Rezepte in dem ich butter
und Schokolade Schmelze das ist schon
mal ein guter Ansatz so aber wir können
diese parat in einer separaten Schüssel
eier und Zucker schaumig schlagen das
ist jetzt z.B anders ich hätte jetzt in
meinem Rezept Zucker hier direkt mit
rein gegeben einfach damit sich die
Zuckerkristalle schon in der Wärme
auflösen ach quatschen sondern schaumig
schlagen genau ich hole meine
Handrührgerät andere Küchenmaschine
so Schneebesen Aufsatz also ich muss
sagen in so äh schriftlichen Rezepten
also in Rezept da ich keine sie alles
erwarten aber fehlt mir noch so
vielleicht so für Backanfänger der
Hinweis
so ja Eier sollten jetzt am besten
Zimmertemperatur haben weil sich das
dann am besten aufsteht oder so man kann
jetzt hier nicht die höchsten Ansprüche
haben ne es soll ja funktionieren so Zug
im Moment mit Zucker direkt eier und
Zucker ja okay also direkt also man muss
sagen diese Beschreibung ist schon immer
sehr kurz und knapp sehr knackig ach so
der kann steht da jetzt nicht ja weiß
ich jetzt auch nicht weißen Stecker rein
oder nicht so richtig für Doofe so und
jetzt ähm da steht auch nicht wie lange
aber schaumig werde ich ja dann sehen
wann es schaumig ist und dann
entsprechend aufhören zu schlagen
[Musik]
wie ist es denn eigentlich weil gerade
wollte ich das von meinem Laptop machen
und dann muss ich jetzt anmelden
über Google verbunden im Endeffekt
wie schaffe ich das meine Frau mich
liebt
[Musik]
was musst du für Daten angeben man muss
auf jeden Fall Krieg hat angeben
[Musik]
also ich würde jetzt in meinem Rezepten
das habe ich mich gerade erklärt ich
würde zum Beispiel sagen die Eier
sollten Zimmertemperatur haben damit es
sich besser aufschlägt vielleicht kannst
du sie ja fragen
müssen die Eier kalt sein mal gucken was
die antwortet da bin ich mal gespannt
nein es ist nicht notwendig dass er kalt
sind wichtig das butter und Schokolade
Anfänger wird jetzt nicht denken weil
meine Eier müssen jetzt kalt sein ich
kann die auch auf Zimmertemperatur
nehmen weil ich muss sagen ich habe
schon oft eier mit Zucker aufgeschlagen
und auf jeden Fall wäre meine Masse wenn
die Eier Zimmertemperatur hätten 2 cm
dicker als jetzt die werden noch
schaumiger gewesen und ich in meinem
Rezept würde jetzt diese diese
Schokomasse abkühlen lassen und nicht
ganz heiß in die Eiermasse zu tun
wenigstens heiß hier rein tue habe ich
persönlich Angst das ist ein bisschen
Rührei bildet also so mache jetzt mal
mein Rezept
das wird ein schlechtes Kochbuch
auf jeden Fall für Backanfänger nicht
ganz so geil weil ich mache jetzt halt
direkt
unter 30 € und dann kommt sowas und
kriegst du dann so ein dummen Tipp oder
es ist sehr kompakt und zusammengefasst
was mache ich wenn sich jetzt um Rührei
bringt aber ich glaube das ist ein
bisschen zu die jetzt die Eier warm
werden
[Musik]
der Eier und dem Zucker ein Zustand
überschlagen stattfindet kann es
passieren dass sie zu werden dies zu
vermeiden empfiehlt es sich der er und
sogar
15 Minuten lang geschlagen und meiner
Maschine da wird kein Rührei draus
Rührei wird doch erstmal hinter dazu
kommen sollte sie es trotzdem zu einem
ungeschlagen kommen kann der Teig
trotzdem verwendet werden aber das
Ergebnis kann unter Umständen nicht so
perfekt aussehen die sagt ja also sie
sagt wenn ihr das zu lange schlägt
passiert Rührei ist es passiert aber es
kann nur passieren wenn der Hitze dazu
kommen also es ist eigentlich diese
dieser Satz schon falsch
ist auch nur mit Kiki Produkten hin so
was ist mein nächstes dann
mehl Kakaopulver Backpulver Salz
hinzufügen alles in einem glatten
okay so das reicht mir hier mit dem
rühren und jetzt kannst du die trockenen
so steht da was von sieben nein okay
also müssen wir nicht sieben würdest du
7 jetzt an der Stelle dadurch dass wir
also hätte ich es richtig schaumig und
fluffig geschlagen hätte ich glaube ich
schon gesehen
und je nachdem wie man es lagert ne man
sie lagern
Backkakao so dass du so Klümpchen
entstehen
gute Parteitag einfach
perfekt das reicht jetzt und was sagt
sie soll ich jetzt machen
okay läuft auf ihrem Schnürchen
die vorbereitete Springform geben und
klatscht streichen das ist aber ein
Tortenring ist nicht schlimm das geht
auch oder Fresse
so nervige kleine Kinder die alles fragt
kennst du deine Kinder wie Alexander
ja schöne Beschäftigung wenn du die
machen vom halswirt möchte
gar nichts mehr weil ich muss noch die
hat mich die hat mich richtig verarscht
das ist jetzt richtig ich hatte ja
gesagt ich habe nur 100 Gramm dunkle
Schokolade was mache ich jetzt und dann
hat sie mir das Rezept irgendwie
halbiert so dass es drei und es fehlt
mir aber die Schokolade weil hier steht
im nächsten Schritt ich dachte jetzt
weißt du aber du brauchst 100 Gramm da
und 100 haben jetzt
bist du Verarsche
auf dem Teig verteilen okay aber du
musst doch erstmal das Einfüllen genau
ich muss jetzt zwei aber ich mache das
mal gerne so wenn ich einen Tortenring
benutze nämlich direkt mein
backblechtern ist nicht mehr so annehmen
muss kannst du dann schon mal wie viel
zu Drittel kannst du dann schon mal zwei
Drittel hole ich die
Zartbitterschokolade
ja das ist so deine Wohnung hier gute
alte Teig aber der kann halt alles ne da
ist noch ein bisschen so bisschen Pulver
soll ich ein bisschen verrühren ja ne ja
bitte schade dann musste das jetzt nicht
in den Zutaten sondern ich musste mir
das Ableiten von der Zubereitung
ein bisschen schwache Leistung muss ich
jetzt mal sagen
olade und dann steht im nächsten Schritt
dass wir die Schokoladen klein und
Stücken auf dem Teig verteilen genau
ich vermute dass sich die
Zartbitterschokolade jetzt im Teig
verfängt das wird vielleicht ein
bisschen klitschig an einigen Stellen
aber es wird glaube ich kein flüssiger
Kern wenn doch dann raste ich aus dann
schmeiße ich das Handtuch jetzt einfach
so drauf
ganz ehrlich wenn ich jetzt mir so die
Masse Schokolade angucke denke doch rein
boah das ist aber schon oder so und da
kommt jetzt der restliche Teig obendrauf
[Musik]
übrigens Titanic kommt ins Kino
und dann verstreichen und dann ab den
Ofen wie lange
[Musik]
so jetzt gucken wir mal nach 30 Minuten
ob das Stäbchen sauber bleibt
[Musik]
vorsichtig rausschieben eigentlich voll
unprofessionell aber ich mache das immer
so schick mir das einmal vor und
ja ich also ich persönlich es ist nicht
sauber weil ich für draußen weil es ist
auch nicht richtig nass also es sieht
schon durchgebacken aus also nach 30
Minuten hole ich ihn jetzt raus und
jetzt wird er natürlich noch warm einmal
angeschnitten ich bin so gespannt ob der
Hitzen flüssiger Kern rauskommen
das hat der gesagt brauchen
wir sind wie wir sind okay ich gebe das
mal hier auf dem Teller hat mal genau
halt stopp halt stopp
jetzt reicht es bleibt einfach so mit
dem Backpapier
ich schneide an ich bin so gespannt okay
oh mein Gott
fertig es fließt schon
[Musik]
oh mein Gott das okay das hätte ich
nicht erwartet
ich bin übertrieben geschockt gerade
guckt euch das mal an das ist doch krank
ich hätte nie damit gerechnet dass das
klappt
so zum Ende absehbar oder ich bin ganz
ehrlich bis zu dem Zeitpunkt jetzt
gerade wo ich rauskomme das klappt nicht
danke
mir ich bin
wirklich sehr sehr lecker
es schmeckt nie weil die schmeckt
richtig günstig bei Burger King aber das
ist die gute Version
aber das ist voll die Sünde meines
Lebens heute
gemacht
keine kalorienbomber
schlecht nein ich finde das echt gut
es war schnell einfach und es schmeckt
das muss diese Sache hier erstmal klar
kommen so das war das letzte Video auf
meinem Kanal nach über 600 und nach über
6 Jahren Youtube Geschichte
dem Hintergrund so eigentlich brauche
ich gar keinen schmeißen wenn sie
verbringen Alter
und keiner wüsste dass es das gemacht
hast ich muss sagen also guck mal ich
bin immer so jemand ich lasse mich
inspirieren nicht nur vom Saison Kinder
sondern auch das Wort was die Community
sagt oder manchmal auf Pinterest einfach
irgendwelche Bilder ich sehe das Bild
und sage ich würde es so und so machen
das ist das gleiche Prinzip ne ich würde
jetzt nicht diesen Chat fragen oder
diese KI Fragen book mir mein Rezept aus
weil dann müsste ich auch das erstmal
wieder hinterleuchten hinterfragen weil
auch da habe ich zum Beispiel gerade
nicht so also ich hätte so ein paar
Sachen anders gemacht definitiv
reingebracht nee ich habe das eigentlich
so gemacht hat aber ich weiß nicht bei
mir ist noch so eine Blockade ich würde
jetzt nicht von ihren Rezept nehmen und
das als Kiki Rezept aufgeben
ja
mit mit 16 wo ich angefangen habe zu
backen in diesem Magazin da habe ich
immer Rezepte machen noch nie geklappt
oder wenn ich mir schon die Zutaten
angeguckt habe das ist kann gar nicht
klappen zu wenig Bindemittel und und und
aber das hier das war jetzt echt gut das
werde ich nicht erwartet
zwei schreibt dann machen wir es richtig
kompliziert
irgendwas oder aber irgendwas
komplizierteres finde ich so eine
Schicht Torte irgendwas kommt
vielleicht keine Ahnung irgendwas
brauchst Agentin oder sowas ich würde
sagen schreibt uns mal den Satz rein den
wir sie fragen sollen also erstelle
erstelle ein Rezept das XY schreibst
einfach rein und wir nehmen dann aus
euren Kommentaren dann das Rezept von
unser nächstes Video
gefallen hat egal nicht bitte melden
genau so und wir können uns sehen auf
jeden Fall schreib
danke dass du mein Gast warst
Schokolade
also
ein paar Sekunden später Leute so
begeistert wie ich heute morgen beim
Dreh war um so enttäuscht da bin ich
jetzt gerade ich musste mich meine
begeisterte Meinung ein bisschen
revidieren denn das Rezept ist wirklich
so ausgelegt das ist nur direkt nach dem
Backen essen können meistens ist es so
dass man das backt und eine Stunde zwei
drei oder auch am nächsten Tag es ist
und es ist einfach so hart geworden und
vom feuchten Kern ist auch nichts mehr
übrig das heißt die Schokolade ist
eigentlich so wie es erwartet habe nach
dem Erkalten halt wieder fest geworden
und somit können wir damit eigentlich
nichts mehr anfangen außer dass man sich
wirklich die Zähne kaputt beißt weil
alles wirklich super hart geworden ist
daher gibt es ein paar Punkte Abzug
[Musik]